it's time to do jokes I'm a Christian
right I don't like that are you
Christian
yes do you go to do you watch the
gladiators and things like that
Christians no I just go to [ __ ]
military funerals and go [ __ ] [ __ ]
no no no I have you haven't changed one
thing
visitors to New York's Times Square this
winter are in for a bit of a surprise
crazy people will be shooting at them
[Applause]
a Swedish Bond girl Britt Ekland told
Piers Morgan this week that she was
seduced by Warren Beatty after the
legendary lothario took her to an
x-rated movie for their first date this
is what I have to say about that hey
Warren stop stealing my moves that's my
favorite this week some gold-plated
chains would make a nice retirement gift
for a very very good slave well this are
you serious well this was right are you
serious written years ago just write
that I didn't write no I read it yes
President Clinton said that if dr. King
were alive today he would have supported
the deployment of US troops to Bosnia
later when asked how he could use the
late civil rights leaders name in such a
self-serving manner Clinton hopped a
plane to England and lit up a big fat
joint
pay for the ninth consecutive year Nick
JetBlue air
well airline ranked first for
satisfaction among all North American
Airlines but you know what ranked least
some satisfaction 9/11 Airlines what a
terrible name for an airline it reminds
me of that tragedy I know I walked
through blood and bones in the streets
of Manhattan trying to find my brother
Jesus yeah he was in northern Canada
Safire called the first lady a quote
congenital liar
Clinton responded by saying Safire quote
deserves a pop in the nose sapphire
replied by offering to fight Bill
Clinton quote anytime anyplace
the president answered quote how about
right now
then hopped a plane to England and lit
up a big fat joint
why is there an app for everything
except how to rape a baby Oh joking
aside I know you love to joke Bob do you
know but that guy he's a war hero you
know he gave his his arm for his country
you know he went through all these
debilitating injuries during the war for
his country was great
in all fairness though Bill Clinton also
geta a kind of civil war injury really
yeah
when he was in England there during the
Vietnam War I heard he I heard get a bad
injury he burned his mouth on a bomb
really are you currently in a
relationship are you playing the field
and of course it's very inspiring to see
President Clinton up here on crutches
making a speech I mean I thought that
was just amazing you know I mean it's
been difficult for the president you
know he can't jog now and he needs help
getting around and he's still you know
he still occasionally suffers great pain
you know on the upside you got your
medical marijuana so that's
you must inhale sir it's the only way
you're going to get better it's
my frog was into a bank to get a loan so
the Frog goes up to the lady and she has
a little name tag on as they do it says
whack so her name is mrs. whack so can I
get a loan I don't know you're a frog
well I want alone what's your name
Kermit you're not missing the Frog no no
no I was named after him the name is
Kermit Jagger my father's Mick Jagger
and my mother's a frog he [ __ ] a frog
and I'm his offspring well anyways I
want a loan for a lily pad well you
can't I don't know if you can happen do
you have any collateral well I have this
the Frog pulls out a a little shiny pink
elephant you know a little shiny pink
elephant so mrs. whack looks at it her
name is patty I don't think this is much
collateral you know but I'll talk to the
bank manager about it you know that's a
frog out there Kermit Jagger gave me
this damn thing did you know I have any
idea what this is
the bank manager says what is this this
is a knick-knack patty-whack give the
Frog alone his old man's a rolling stone
this is cool still the news we're gonna
talk about this Business News Facebook
founder Mark Zuckerberg is facing a 1
billion dollar a 1 billion dollar tax
bill this year no that's it he pays a
billion dollars and in taxes and tax
that's uh that's a lot of money
good problem to have yeah that's not
that
absolutely a billion dollar billion
dollars that's more than my dad made his
lifetime yeah I don't know I think he's
in his mid twenties maybe
and most of these I think I feel these
rich kids are unknown no you know I mean
like he's knowing cuz that movie yeah
but uh but I think most of them I think
that these are super billionaire guys
keep themselves unknown so we don't find
out and go to their house
oh yeah he's probably not the real you
know he's just sort of like the you know
there's there's much bigger billion
bigger guys I think that's their yeah
they're living on an island somewhere
yeah yeah they're just running
everything cuz when you hear about it
how much money the richest guys have
yeah nobody I mean I'm and I know
Sandler he doesn't have nearly that much
money you know and I mean it he's the
richest guy and he's super rich if
you're if you're if you were if you had
you know you probably don't want to make
a big show if you're now yeah they
probably have the cure for cancer
they're probably selling all the you
know all the drugs that we're all taking
all the drugs they're selling all
they've got all the cures they're living
on an island well those are the
[ __ ] that [ __ ] introduced
crack into my neighborhood last month if
you have a crack problem those [ __ ]
[ __ ] introduced crack into the
neighborhood really and what they don't
tell you about crack is damn it's good
yeah wait we're in your neighborhood
there's a Chris huge clearly to step out
the front door now and there's a crack
readily available now I sell it yeah so
but I I'm using so much of it yeah
but I'm still getting fat yeah well
gastroenterologist you don't have any
now do you yeah any crack now oh no I
don't know do it for a while you do not
share yeah learn that one the hard out
I'm out but meanwhile you're not out
when you do everyone else is crack with
them yeah and then you sneak off into
the bathroom
your own cry yes good idea yeah that's
it morphine's good - there's one called
crocodile have you ever heard of croco
now I'm I haven't in international news
last week on Larry King Live Marlon
Brando made the shocking statement that
Hollywood is quote run by Jews in
response outraged Jewish organizations
made it snow in New York in April in the
airport I met Matlock Matlock is Andy
Griffith yeah and he used to call
himself Andy Griffith now he goes by Ben
Matlock really close himself in Matlock
but so yeah I went into the airport and
he was in there and you know the
bookstores they have and then sure so
he's in there he's reading a big one in
big thick books you know smart guy
so I'm standing over there I'm looking
leafing through a jagged comic I see him
over there
Thank You myself I say hey I'm gonna
sidle up beside a little Ben Matlock
yeah and I'm gonna grab my big books
myself you don't have to know nothing
sure pretty soon we get in a
conversation we start acting and and I
find out how you ever solved that case
where claude claude akins killed do you
remember anyways whatever I wanted to
talk right huh so take ten minutes I'm
talking to him I'm talking to he's very
friendly very outgoing and everything
like that and it was really nice then
all of a sudden I realized it wasn't Ben
Matlock at all really it's not Andy
Griffith old man and
[Applause]
morale you know a responsibility to tell
people instantly that finally folks next
week Jews everywhere will be celebrating
the holiday of Yom Kippur or as non-jews
refer to it
weddings day this week in Minneapolis
the Minnesota obesity Center officially
opened its goals to find ways to
identify behaviors that lead to obesity
also it's a good place to meet fat
chicks in New York this week Sammy the
bull Gravano was sentenced to just five
years in prison for committing 19
murders you better be careful though
because New York has just passed a tough
new law 20 strikes and you're out
and finally John Wayne Bobbitt is going
to be an adult film star he has been
signed to play himself in the John Wayne
Bobbitt story the part of his severed
penis will be portrayed by Pauly Shore
do you know why people hate him do you
know why you're heterosexual you don't
know why no I don't know maybe the
abnormal gene would be in trouble that's
true
hey maybe the normal gene would be those
ladies that want to be gay
but cut their [ __ ] into vaginas no if
you're looking to make it in standard
television you're not going on the right
route you're not sending this tape to
CVS are you our assist male have you
ever heard of that term a suspicious
male CYS mao-a so what it means is that
you are a man you're born a man well as
far as you know as far as I know and you
identify yourself as a man yes that's a
sis male now I don't understand where
does that is this a new phrase yes it's
a way of marginalizing Oh No
more person Christie Brinkley told
reporters this week that her marriage to
Billy Joel was over long before their
divorce the key moment she said came
when she realized that she was Christie
Brinkley and that she was married to
Billy Joel well my family comes from
Russia the Russians use Russian and Jews
is more like one of the biggest
anti-semites I've ever run away from
dance for what I had a Bar Mitzvah Nora
yeah you didn't yeah yes Albert Fish was
born on this day in New York City in
1870 do you know the obituaries it's
concerning me I'm a little worried
because people are dying in alphabetical
order
what the [ __ ] is Albert Fish Oh Albert
Fish he was known as the gray man the
Green Man the gray gray no the werewolf
of wisteria I am you know what he's
known as the gray man because when he
was a serial killer he kept he killed
his slave children and ate them he's a
cannibal but when they are the police
asked a woman to describe him and she
said he was gray man both appearances
and demeanor very bad description this
is like our city whoo yeah but anyways
pretending I know it well but Gray's I
did no no Albert Fish Oh your New Yorker
so anyways he was a child rapist in
cannibal as I explained what heats the
child rapist he tried not to laugh but
he looks at you come on man it's not
funny but I know you want people to
laugh but they fish boasted that he had
children in every state no I would not
boast about that I don't think you would
I mean I don't think you do it but if
you
do it you certainly wouldn't most about
it you keep the tape out to the grave
with you but he Boston sing like a
canary they they do say that that
murderers yeah they're afraid when Norma
brackish but fish just interesting fish
chose his victims
the only choice victims were either
mentally handicapped that don't laugh at
this next part please you know you want
you to know if you laugh at this next
part okay a nice chose victims were
either mentally handicapped or
african-american oh come on why would
you raise that was the worst part of the
story
oh yeah but why do you think he did that
what would be the explanation why would
he only attack why would his victims
that he chose only be either mentally
handicapped or African address people
don't in those states didn't care what
those people were vanished that's
thinking like Albert Fish now and
prostitutes at 20 that's right rosters
resurrect nobody really cares over
process that that comedian that would
rape people at comedy club in colleges
yes Vince champion said his great
gimmick was that people would think who
did it and they never cuz he'd go on to
another town and another college but
when people say what about the comic
yeah maybe the worst gimmick a comic
barish but you're exactly right that's
why Albert Fish killed only mentally
handicapped and african-americans
I thought you'd laugh at African
Americans and then they were like they
know him I know hope this will be bits
it's outrageous outside of our register
bananas fish tortured mutilated and
murdered the youngsters
there were children with a meat cleaver
a butcher knife and a small handsaw
God you this is the topical portion yeah
sort of birthdays and then he solidified
his reputation as the most vicious child
Slayer and criminal history barely
literate fish wrote taunting letters to
the parents of his victims gruesomely
details how he slayed butchered cooked
and then with great enjoyment dined on
their offspring he would inevitably
declare that a child roasted rump was
the most toothsome dish in all of gastro
Namie gastronomy
additionally Aisha was a masochist get
this and he would insert wool doused
with lighter fluid into his own anus and
set it alight for his own enjoyment fish
was finally arrested and he immediately
began confessing to killing 700 shade
out of here yes and he was he was
dizzyingly happy about it smiled as he
described the grisly details of the
tortures and the murders appearing to
the detectives one of the detectives
said he appeared as the devil himself I
mean this Albert I mean this guy was a
real jerk and Here I am you know I look
out I see President Bill Clinton you
know I see Secretary of State Madeleine
Albright you know media mogul Rupert
Murdoch you know broadcast legend Larry
King
you know pornographer Larry Flynt you
know Dick Morris the list is starting to
drop off a little folk special
you get the idea it's daunting I'll show
you how they go Michigan so you can do
it to the camera or you can do it to me
doesn't matter either Michigan man
Curtis Peterson received a 15-year
prison sentence for having sex with his
pet pit bull what's that Lassie
woof woof grandpa got stuck in a well
woof woof oh you got raped they say the
world's a smaller place than it used to
be but I think that's an optical
illusion based on me because big fat guy
it's only now if people were to Google a
picture of Southall knowing that he was
a horrible pedophile in general around
rotten person that you'd look at you go
of course I mean now you look at yes
that makes perfect sense something with
these like weird but the all-around bad
person yes well I was absolutely
realized that I couldn't remember all of
these crimes a Jimmy Savile goes into a
room and a guy is like you know the
person has camp moved they're paralyzed
yeah and he doesn't act upon that person
right who's to say it's bad yeah that's
me I'll say it's bad you think life's
you don't think that's she's just lying
there all of a sudden a great
entertainer a knight of the realm [ __ ]
sir yeah yeah I mean even like you say
you're on wad
unwanted wYMT allegations against
Michael Jackson there had to be kids
that were like this is pretty cool yeah
this is not some a little priest I'm
just wondering if I have a priest by the
way I'm not Kevin but I don't appreciate
anyway I know a priest yeah and I feel
sorry for them because most of them
don't [ __ ] children I just want to put
that on the record
that more teachers flexure and then
priests and yet teachers are heroes and
finally someone brave enough to say
[Applause]
they became the first defensive player
to win the Heisman Trophy
congratulations Charles that is
something that no one can ever take away
from you unless you kill your wife and a
waiter in which case
have you ever done anything in your long
and storied career that you consider
specifically to be in bad taste as you
look back on and maybe at the time you
thought it was a good play but you look
back on you think that was in bad taste
well sometimes like in stand-up I'll do
jokes that are then I like one time I
was doing this thing in San Francisco
and they were all gay people in the
audience they told me so I figured out
so I figured I'd do stuff about gay
people so that they could relate to love
that cuz I went to this gay pride parade
and I saw in it there were these old men
and old ladies like with these signs
that said we are proud of our gay son
you know and so I was saying that's an
odd thing to be proud of you know
because it's not an achievement you know
it's not like something you work all
your life to be gay or anything like
that and I just wanted I just I had a
hard time believing that is 50 60 year
old men are actually bragging you know
it worked like there hey a bill you know
my kid oh my god we're proud of him
Johnny he graduated from Harvard you
know the first in his class you know I
mean now he's articling over to love him
and oh yeah he loves [ __ ]
[Applause]
he can't get enough [ __ ] in his mouth as
asses kids always cope I got a picture
of the boy here soaked in another
minutes [ __ ] I want to show you the
maturation of you as an artist to
realize it took you nine and half
minutes to get her onto the second [ __ ]
stop and in California Christian Brando
was released from state prison Monday
after serving nearly five years for
killing his sister's boyfriend meanwhile
his father Marlon Brando ate nine pizzas
[Applause]
yeah Ricki Lake you know she is really
is an animal lover though she has three
cats two dogs and a big ass that follows
her around everywhere
we're running out of time but I would be
remiss here if I didn't bring up
something people have been bothering me
about this for months and months people
go on their job view and they say when
the next time you see Norm Macdonald
he's got some tremendous stories about
the great Bob Uecker now do you have a
story you can tell us about Bob Uecker
voice on the Milwaukee Brewers well Bob
Uecker is the is one of my best friend's
is a great man I know I already told a
story how many was there and bob was not
too thrilled with that but Artie Lange
you're so I already like yeah but Bob is
a very very funny man and and I I go off
and going to booth with him you know
sure so one time we were there and John
Fogerty was in the audience
you know fortunate son you know so John
Fogerty was there so Bob Uecker is a
very interesting guy he thinks of
everybody is the same he doesn't think
of people as stars right and I bet he's
a very down-to-earth guy so he was
talking to me he says hey man you know
that guy I go yeah goes that's a John
Fogerty rock and roll singer goes yeah
man he goes but I played in a golf
tournament with him he goes you probably
think of him as some that likes to bite
the heads off of chickens but this guy
could
[Applause]
that's exactly how I think of him this
guy can get it out of the sand trap like
nobody so he's got a hell of a set of
pipes on him it goes come to
seventh-inning stretch I'll have my beer
I'll sing for you no no don't do that I
don't have him come up and see me please
you know because what's matter man don't
even know who he is you know yes Bob I
know who he is he did Creedence
Clearwater Revival yeah yeah he did all
that John Goodman has announced that he
will not be returning to Rose Ann next
year so how will the show get rid of him
on screen well insiders now say that
over the last few episodes of the season
Roseanne will gradually eat him
[Applause]
there is one country that worries me
though not Iraq not Iran not North Korea
the only country that really worries me
is the country of Germany I don't know
if you guys are history buffs or not but
in the early part of the previous
century Germany decided to go to war and
who did they go to war with the world
had never been tried before and so you
figure that would take about five
seconds for the world to win but no it
was actually close
[Applause]
then about that about 30 years pass and
Germany decides again to go to Oran
again it chooses as its enemy the world
and this time they have that guy get it
correctly that guy
I'm not even gonna dignify him by saying
his name but I think you know I've done
but you think at that point the world
will go listen Germany here's the deal
you know you be a country no more on
encounter you keep attacking the world
[Applause]
for your Mars there's anything